In a highly unusual, move U.S. Ambassador
to South Africa has publicly accused the government
is delivering arms and ammunition to Russia.
He says that -- were loaded on a sanctioned
Russian target ship at a naval base near cape
time.
Joining me now and is -- from johannesburg.
What more can you tell us about this, will
there be reprisals?
>> Certainly, it was something that caught
the attention of many people in December,
Bianca, when the sanctioned -- enable the
station in Cape Town.
They turned off the transponders, and according
to witnesses an opposition, and members of
parliament, they on loaded and the dead of
night.
At that point there were a lot of questions
asked, and a lot of -- from the south African
government about what was exactly going on.
Subsequent to that, we have this bombshell
announcement, by the U.S. Ambassador, to local
[8:13:48 AM]
the U.S. Ambassador, to local media here in
South Africa, saying they wore south African
dealings with Russia.
Point blank, say that they're placed arms
and ammunition on that sanction vessel that
was bound for Russia.
I did not provide proof, and there has been
a continued fallout of the statements that
the department of international relations,
and cooperation say they're bringing the ambassador
in for a talking to today.
There will be discussions between -- and Hayes
counterpart and south Africa today.
The question is, why did the Americans make
this very public announcement?
I think it's based on a long-standing frustration,
and maybe the straw that broke the camel's
back at the U.S. Saying that while South Africa
says that it's not aligns when it comes to
Russia's invasion of Ukraine, the U.S.
And some western powers don't necessarily
believe that based
[8:14:49 AM]
necessarily believe that based on the south
government action.
You have the latest news of allegedly these
arms going to Russia.
Before, that South Africa hosted -- the south
Africans have repeatedly abstain from condemning
Russia.
The U.N. Secretary general, who had the general
assembly, excuse, me points to and trend that
I think these western diplomats feel.
It's showing the South Africa's leading the
Russian direction.
What comes next?
The government will have an inquiry, they
have been denied these accusations.
There is a very important and strategic trade
relationship with the U.S.
That they'll need to protect if they're looking